she said stormy Webster just told her no
you near mama - zip it she's done that
before Tommy - yeah
Kylie Jenner's two-year-old baby girl
with rapper Travis Scott was hanging out
with her famous mom watching frozen -
for the first time and it was all fine
and dandy until Kylie made the mistake
of talking over the Disney flick snow
we're watching frozen - for the first
time into a at the fence I just turned
to tell her I love her
[Music]
Chuck she's never done that before
tell me - Shh Charlie see very nice
movie not only did stormy her mom but
she also used Kylie's space as a
footrest
[Music]
the look on Kylie's face though is it
just me or his stormy like quickly
becoming the biggest star in the
kardashian-jenner family recently shared
this adorable clip of her baby girl to
Instagram that's not my name my name is
mommy no yeah that's stormy circling
around her famous mama calling her by
her first name
that's not my name's mommy can you even
handle that cuteness
it's fun just in case that wasn't sweet
enough oh she loves bagels
Kylie recently told Harper's Bazaar that
stormy stands of bagel the other night I
always wonder what does this little girl
dream about and we were sleeping she
woke up out of her sleep and said bagel
and I was like if she awake right now
and I looked over dead asleep dreaming
about bagels relatable not so relatable
Stormies over the top 2nd birthday party
another you want to go inside yeah it
was basically a full-on stormy themed
amusement park that also included a
frozen world section troll should we go
to choice world frozen worlds
throw me world first look at these maps
see how that all comes full circle so
we're watching frozen - for the first
time after the epic birthday bash Kylie
shared this family pic of her with itty
bitty stormy and her ex Travis Scott a
source recently told ET quote Kylie and
Travis truly enjoy one another and are
in love but it can often be hard
navigating their lives at such a young
age
the couple needed to take a step back to
reevaluate many things but in doing so
they are better now than ever and they
really seem to be nailing this whole
co-parenting thing something that she
might just have learned from her Big
Sisters Khloe and Kourtney feel like we
are doing our best to make everything
feel super normal for the kids I think
you just gotta figure out really what's
important to you at the end of the day
when et caught up with quartz ex Scott
Disick and Khloe in 2019 they opened up
about the hard work it takes at the end
of the day I mean you just want to be
happy you want to be content you want to
be comfortable life is a challenge and
if you work at what you want you can get
it but it takes hard work simple as that
you can easily live less of a life
without working as hard and that's a few
minutes hard work for all parties okay
but enough about all that let's get back
to all that baby cuteness my name's
mommy
so I'm petitioning for more stormy on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians who's
with me
just me okay make sure to stick with ET
for all things Kylie and sweet little
stormy but until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens and these
can you even handle that cuteness no you
can't no one can
it's too cute that's just weird you
don't have to use that anyway
[Laughter]